[Musique]
ce mardi 8 août s'est en bordure de la
rivière des galets à Saint-Paul que le
président du département en Cyril
Melchior a donné rendez-vous au
partenaire pour le coup d'envoi du
chantier de construction d'une
microcentrale hydroélectrique la poste
de la première pierre s'est déroulée en
présence des vice-présidents Gilbert
délégués à l'eau et Serge Hoarau
président de la saphir ainsi que de la
directrice de l'Agence française de
développement qui a participé au
financement de cette opération notre
contribution au financement des étés de
faisabilité était de 200.000 euros en
subvention et par ailleurs je rappelais
historiquement la FD était un très gros
financeur mais cette fois sur près à
travers le financement du de
l'investissement du département du
budget d'investissement du département
on a été un très gros financeur du grand
projet
îlot de basculement des eaux vers le
littoral Ouest la future microcentrale
de la Rivière des Galets rec pas les
eaux rejetés par le réservoir de mon
repos lui-même alimenté par les ouvrages
de basculement des eaux cette turbine
d'une puissance de 500 kW permettra à
terme de produire 2,7 gigawh il y en a
déjà deux qui ont été installés par le
passé aujourd'hui nous entamons les
travaux pour une troisième micro au
centrale en rive gauche de l'arrivée
c'est la contribution du département à
la vocation à l'autonomie énergétique de
l'île sur cette microcentrale nous
allons produire de l'électricité
permettant d'alimenter l'équivalent de
1000 familles mais c'est pas le
département qui va distribuer cette
électricité nous allons mettre cette
électricité à disposition d'EDF
l'opérateur historique en misant sur les
sources d'énergie renouvelables comme
ici l'énergie hydroélectrique le
département poursuit son plan mégawatt
avec l'objectif de devenir une
collectivité à énergie positive d'ici
en produisant plus d'électricité que ce
qu'elle en consomme
[Musique]